so the new Dragon Ball anime dragon ball
DA has finally been announced and I feel
like the one element in particular not
getting enough attention is the art
style the thing that most blows my mind
about this series is that it is the
first time we have gotten toriyama's
modern style directly adapted into anime
form after Toriyama finished writing
Dragon Ball his style of drawing Dragon
Ball continued to evolve and ended up
settling on something like this
different looking eyes hair muscles the
whole nine yards and anytime he would
create a design for future animes such
as the movies or even Dragon Ball super
his designs would be in this style but
up until now that modern Toriyama style
has always been ignored in favor of the
Dragon Ball super art style but now
after Decades of waiting we can finally
see what an anime with toriyama's modern
sensibilities will actually look like
and I honestly can't wait for that